overall i rate the possibility of erie
returning maria's quirk
as a nine out of ten i do believe that
this is the most likely course of action
and obviously given everything that's
happened erie feels a massive debt to
him massive
debt to him massive debt to him
what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain how lemelian
finally got his quirk back in my here
academia and we're also going to work
out the timeline of events
it's been over three years since the
manga chapter came out where he
originally lost it
and since then he's had a very
diminished role after the cultural
festival was over
quercus muria was only seen a handful of
times and on every occasion it was very
brief
he's also been on break from his studies
this entire time which has resulted in
several janitor miriam memes
which we've had to endure for too long
too long guys
but thankfully all those memes can now
be put to rest
as million has you know he returned out
of nowhere basically
in chapter 292 and in the following
chapter we now have an explanation
for how his permeation quirk came back
just before we get into it be sure to
hit that sub button for more explanation
videos like this
and also thank you guys for getting the
channel to 150k
subs you know we started this year with
less than 15 000
so to be at 150k which is you know 10
times that
it's like a dream come true and i
honestly can't thank every one of you
enough
but with that said let's get into the
video and to start things off you can
probably tell by the intro
muriel was able to get his quirk back
thanks to the help of erie
major spoilers ahead for chapter 293 but
some time ago it appears that bubblegirl
told murio about the plan
for heroes across japan to ambush the
villains
this ambush is truly the thing that
began the war arc
and lamilian desperately wanted to
participate but in his mind
the only way he could get the power to
do this would be for erie to rewind him
and so he approached her about doing so
if we flush back to when mirio
originally lost his quirk
he said to deku that he'd ask erie to
rewind him if she learned how to control
her power at some point
and since then we know that she's been
training with izawa
the professor made her practice the
rewind quirk on insects and lizards
which has allowed her to gain some
degree of control as a result
muriel asked erie to rewind him and he
apologized for needing to use her power
but you know from the panel it was clear
that eri was happy to do this
as she tells him not to say sorry
because this is the moment that she's
been practicing for
from the beginning mirio has done a lot
for arie you know i mean besides
messing up that one time and letting her
go back to overhaul the fact is that he
sacrificed his quirk
and he's also given her his undivided
attention
and a ton of emotional support so this
is her way of repaying everything he's
done
and you know what i cannot wait to see
this animated with the soundtrack
playing in the back
you know that's gonna that's gonna get
me in the feels i'm pretty sure
now that he's back my next thought is
how long was he actually quirkless
because
you know although i was sure erie was
going to rewind him one day
i didn't think it would be so soon when
mirio made his appearance in chapter 292
this day was at the end of march so
presumably the 31st of march is when we
see him with his power
we already know from the anime that
muriel lost his quirk in early october
of the previous year
autumn had just begun when everything
began to go down so it's safe to say
that it was early october
that means there's a time period of just
under six months
between mario losing his quirk and when
we see him with his quirk again
in the grand scheme of things six months
is not really that long of a time period
um that being said though you know when
we look at it in real world terms
it has been three years since he lost
his quirk in the manga so i guess
horikoshi was just tired and was just
like you know what
i'm gonna give him the quirk back it's
been three years i may as well do this
one thing
i can't blame him if that's the reason
if he just got tired of miriam not being
able to do anything
after three real world years now that we
know that erie can rewind people in a
controlled manner
then of course deku hawkes mirko izawa
all might and i'm sure many others could
do with a quick airy operation
the main limitation is that erie needs
to wait until the horn on her head gets
bigger before she can rewind people
and the last time we saw her her horn
was just totally tiny
meaning that any injuries sustained
during the war arc
will have to wait a while before she's
able to rewind them let me know your
thoughts down below on this
do you think erie's existence kind of
erases
consequences in this universe like when
we know that at some point eric can
always rewind someone who's lost a quirk
or
lost an arm or something like that does
it kind of lower the stakes
in my opinion it does a little bit but
again
she does have that limitation there and
at the moment we don't know how long it
takes her
to build up to another rewind you know
is it one month is it two months
we just don't know how long it takes um
but when we get more information on her
quirk then i guess it's easier to form
an opinion
anyway guys this was just a quick video
breaking down
how muriel got his quirk back and
remember i'll be doing a live breakdown
of chapter 293
this sunday on twitch so be sure to
click the link in the description if you
want to see that
and until the next one peace out